I am very pleased that John White has
agreed to talk with me today about our
accountability system in the United
States and the various efforts to raise
standards through common core and
through many other actions taken at
state levels John White is the state
superintendent for education for the
state of Louisiana and was also deputy
Chancellor in New York City so it has a
breadth of knowledge about how the
intergovernmental system needs to work
and it's very especially interesting to
talk with somebody who has been so
successful in Louisiana at raising
student performance from what was
seconds at the bottom to the most
rapidly improving state in the United
States under his leadership
so John it's great to have you with me
today great event and I would like to
ask you is testing an important part of
your thinking is holding schools
accountable an important part of your
thinking about how you get gains in
student performance and a more effective
educational system it is and no question
that measurement is has to be an
important component of any plan for
success there's a lot of ways we can
improve testing a lot of ways that we
can improve our accountability systems
the every student succeeds act I think
at least calls us to can seriously
consider those questions in the States
there are some serious risks involved in
all of this too but no question if you
the step to begin to measure learning is
an important one it can be done better
it can be done more efficiently but it's
a critical component as a starting point
of any plan for change well just a lot
of people were on board with this idea
back in 2002 when No Child Left Behind
was introduced into Congress and a
bipartisan coalition Democrats and
Republicans alike supported aspire
helming margin but as time went on a lot
of opposition developed to the testing
and the holding schools accountable that
was required by No Child Left Behind
what did they do wrong or why did that
political opposition develop well I
think there's a difference between what
was done wrong and what why the
political opposition develops but I
think that in terms of what was done
wrong the president has talked about
this there it has spawned an industry no
question about that and and I'm not sure
if every element of that industry is
what we want we don't need our kids
taking tests every day multiple times
over the course of a day it should be a
checkup and that's what it is and it's
fair to say that we or the establishment
or industry have not effectively
communicated to parents this is how this
benefits you this is not just a crusade
to benefit the disenfranchised this is
for everybody this is beneficial and we
haven't done as much as we needed to to
communicate that but one of the mistakes
that I thought was made by No Child Left
Behind was the adequate yearly progress
way of defining what was a good school
instead of looking at how much kids are
learning in the course of one year how
much more do they know this year than
they did one year ago which I would have
thought would have been the logical way
of trying to find out of the school's
effective or not the good news is people
I think discovered that you know quickly
years into No Child Left Behind that the
idea of just how many students are at a
certain level in a certain school is not
really an effective way of measuring the
effect of that school you know in our
state for example if you look at the a
schools the schools that are rated a
thirty percent of its mean in some
schools 90 percent of struggling
students in those schools are hitting
the mark in some state in some of those
a rated schools only thirty percent of
the struggling students are hitting the
mark so you've got wide wide differences
when you really dig into the data behind
what is in an a school so you will give
an A to a school where the students are
performing at a fairly low level if
they're showing substantial improvement
from one year to this well I think we
should do that I think right now what we
do and I probably didn't explain it as
well as I should have but what we do is
we give aid to schools that are making
great strides with kids we also give
aids to some schools that aren't making
great strides but just have
high-performing kids to begin with and
there's obviously a distinction
they're in a school can be one where
kids are just performing at a high level
but it can also be one where kids came
performing at a deplorable low level and
then really made games that's an A also
and we need to redefine in our state and
in many states what constitutes in a
school now the state school chief
officers I've forgotten exactly how that
name goes but and the governor's the
National Governors Association agreed to
put into place Common Core State
Standards that was backed by the Obama
administration with its race to the top
and initiative and its waiver policies
so that states didn't have to abide by
some of those NCLB requirements if in
fact they would adopt the Common Core
State Standards and make other reforms
as well so once again this this at the
beginning had widespread support and
well that's first of all talk about that
widespread support do do you agree that
it was there at the beginning I do and
the most simple way that I can I can
rationalize it to my in my mind and for
those that I work with is we have
historically been the 48th or 49th
ranked state in the country and
academics we have historically been in
the top five in football the reason
we're in the top five in football is
because we're willing to go to any state
and we're willing to compete but in
academics it's always just been well how
did one town in Louisiana do against
another town we can't get to the top in
a valid way unless we're willing to go
to any state and put our education
system up against it that's how you grow
that's how you progress is you're
willing to open your doors and to
compete so the principles of success on
the football field are principles of
success in our academic system if we
don't have something that we share with
other states the ability to measure
ourselves against everybody else there's
not really a valid platform for how we
need to progress but a lot of people
feel like okay the history of education
in the South in general Louisiana
included is very different than the
history of Education in the Northeast
where you've had back to the days of the
pilgrims a real commitment to teaching
children early on
is it fair to put them all on the same
platform and say you've got to be
compared to those people in other parts
of the country not just your own well
date you know there's a difference
between what's fair to the adults and
what's fair to the students and you need
to be fair to both we have 300 years of
subjugation of African American people
in our state we are an agrarian state
that is coming into a 21st century
economy and natural resources state I'm
not going to argue that that's a
different that that's the same
conditions in which Massachusetts or New
York or state in the Northeast operates
in clearly we come into this from a
different perspective but what is fair
to the kids who are inheriting in the
year 2016 a multinational seriously
competitive economy is to have
expectations that are those that the
workforce will have for them which is
you should be able to work and live and
succeed anywhere what's there to the
adults is not to demoralize everybody
just because you have those high
expectations and you can do both of
those things you can have a system that
has the highest expectations possible
for children while having a rational
system of improvement for the adults who
operate the system so the common core
standards principle is one that you
endorse you continue to endorse despite
the political opposition that developed
on both the right and the left of the
political spectrum is he party opposed
it a lot of teacher unions opposed it a
lot of teachers have opposed Common Core
so why I'm going to ask especially about
the teachers why did why did opposition
to Common Core State Standards develop
among teachers I support the principle
of what those standards in body which is
interstate competition you know we have
our own standards in Louisiana called
the Louisiana student standards that
allow us to remain comparable with
states across the country and I support
those standards with respect to teachers
first there is no one teacher voice and
I am sick and tired of people saying
that teachers be viewed as our teachers
believe it that way every year I get in
a room with five or six thousand
teachers in New Orleans for a group of
gathering called our teacher leaders
there are five or 6,000 different views
about a lot of different stuff in there
but there is no one in
that room was just against progress and
I actually think that when you engage
teachers in a conversation you empower
them with curriculum that they actually
know is aligned to the standards they
get fired up about the state standards
in our case Louisiana student standards
there may have been I think some steps
along the way that didn't give teachers
the tools they needed to be confident
when they were doing it when you're cut
not confident you're fearful and when
you're fearful you say it and that
happened a lot in some states including
our own occasionally but I think we've
bridged that cap we've gotten beyond it
and I'll say I don't feel any more
support for high expectations from any
group more than I do from teachers what
I think I'm hearing John is that you're
saying there's been a lot of political
conflict over common core state
standards but this movement toward
setting standards that are closer to
being the same across the state is not
going to go away is there's more and
deeper support we've seen this with our
education next poll that in fact there
is a lot of support for similar
standards across the country and I don't
know if that's just what people say in
response to questions that or but but I
think I hear you're saying that there is
support for that I believe that in a
state that has historically been rated
low that our kids are born just as smart
and just as capable as any kids in this
country I believe they have gifts and
talents that are no lesser than those
are the children in any other state and
I believe the people of Louisiana want
controlled the education system there
but they also support the idea that our
kids can compete and deserve a level
playing field and they shouldn't have to
wait until the AC teen 11th grade to get
it
well we have a new law called the
education oh I can't remember how every
student succeeds Act every student
succeeds Act so how is this affecting
the whole setting of standards and the
setting of accountability that's a big
question and I think it's a big if
states have a lot more control even
districts have a lot more control over
these questions and they did under not
just No Child Left Behind but the
waivers to No Child Left Behind and I
think whether States make a decision
that on some elements they're going to
compete that's still left up in the air
states also now have the
to use measures in their system that
aren't just about tests and how
innovative those things will be how much
of a free pass those things will be and
it goes a lot up in the air on those
questions so we don't know exactly where
we're going
in our educational system as we enter
the latter part of the second decade of
the 21st century there's a lot of
questions yet to be answered but if we
don't improve our schools work how are
we going to be a continually prosperous
country as we move into the 21st century
it would be impossible for us to be and
you know my hope and I do believe that
in many states this will happen is it
will go back to the record and we'll see
that the following formula is a good
formula for success one high
expectations that are measured in a way
where they can be validated across state
lines to an acceptance that our
accountability system does need to
evolve there are higher achieving
systems around the world that have non
tested measures look at New Zealand for
example and look at what they've done
with their system to great effect and
three when schools go off the rails and
we all in every state have these issues
you need to be able to intervene but
we've got a decade of research now to
show what works and what doesn't so if
you are willingness willing to embrace
change willing to embrace high
expectations and follow the research
when there's problems that's a formula
for success I don't see why a state
would go in a different direction from
that and if we do it'll work thank you
John this has been a great opportunity
to get to understand your philosophy and
your strategy for school reform thank
you very much thanks Paul
you